16 and it's not sweet but that is the
number of legal actions filed to keep
Trump off State ballots in 2024 now I'm
actually surprised that number is not
higher frankly given what we've seen But
suffering from Trump derangement
syndrome and a deep deep anxiety about
Biden's mental and physical state some
are even willing to jettison the
Constitution as in your right to protest
we live under the rule of law in this
country and and it's imperative that all
Americans accept the decisions of our
courts including the Supreme Court of
the United States it is not an option in
the United States of America to protest
in the streets uh decisions of of our
courts state or or
federal look at the people react they're
like what did you just said since when
because we know that they love it when
certain people take to the streets the
BLM peaceful protest they were lovely
and the Uproar over the dobs
[Applause]
decision burn it down they were saying
joining us now to explain the
implications of gutting the right to
free assembly free expression Jonathan
Turley professor of law at GW and a Fox
News contributor uh Professor these
comments weren't from some you know
random lawyer in town these were from a
former well-respected conservative judge
on the fourth Circuit Court of
Appeals well you you hear this type of
uh exaggerated claim uh with a lot of
folks in this superheated environment
you have members of Congress for example
that have said that hate speech is not
protected it is protected uh you know
hate crimes are not protected but hate
speech is uh it's hateful we all
denounce it but the first amendment is
there to protect unpopular speech even
speech that uh we may condemn uh but
there is nothing new to this right you
have Democrats who are now literally
running for office on the pledge of
censorship I mean think about that right
you have people running for office
pledging to Citizens that they will
reduce their constitutional rights
that's what we have reached as as a
country now in the end I think there's
of us in this country to hold the line
to say that that's not what defines us
what defines us are these common rights
these values and that means that we
often defend others that we disagree
with we don't censor them we don't
arrest
them well I think what we've seen is a a
panic has set in because everything
they've done from calling Trump Hitler
or ppot or Stalin whatever the latest is
or saying he's the big threat to
democracy yet the boomerang is thrown by
them they're throwing this this claim
out at Trump and and then it's coming
back and hitting them because they don't
seem to really want to trust the voters
next year Jonathan they do not trust
what the outcome of the election will be
if it's just let to
go well you know Laura the best way to
be a defender of democracy is actually
practice democracy to actually support
it just say that Citizens need to go to
the polls and to argue that they
shouldn't vote for Donald Trump or
should not vote for Joe Biden that's
democracy in action but instead you have
four justices at the Colorado Supreme
Court that want to prevent millions of
people from voting for what is currently
the leading candidate for the presidency
but you also have people like the New
York Times editor that recently said
that anyone who questions this ruling is
standing with Confederates so you're not
standing with the Constitution you're
standing with the Confederacy and it's
that type of overheated rhetoric that we
all have to be unified in condemning you
know there were three Democratic
justices in Colorado that refused to
sign on to this this was the first
successful major ruling the those
earlier rulings were also uh rejected by
many Democrats so there's more Unity
here than people suggest but what they
hear in this cacophony particularly on
some other works is this sort of false
narrative you're the these viewers are
hearing that this is a slam dunk that
it's unassailable that it's clear that
he could be taken from this ballot and
those are and you can understand why
those voters get angry when they hear
from the courts no you know this is a a
bridge too far for a
democracy Now a quick reaction here
Jonathan um special prosecutor Jack
Smith he's uh frantically appealing to
the Supreme Court urging them not to
waste any time and taking up the
president a question of President
Trump's immunity argument writing this
afternoon the special counsel insisting
that the resolution of the question
presented is pivotal to whether the
former president himself will stand
trial the public interest and a prompt
resolution favors an immediate
definitive decision the charges here are
of the utmost gravity uh they want this
done and if they can it seems to be at
least they want him in jail before the
election how do you see
this well you're very familiar with this
court of course and the question is
whether the Supreme Court itself will
share this sense of urgency you know
Smith has pulled out all the stops to
make sure that he can try and in his
view hopefully convict Trump before the
election these justices may not see that
urgency even if you convict Trump he's
still eligible to be president he can
still run and and serve even if you were
to convict him so the question is why
pull the stops on this why not stick
with regular order and allow the court
of appeals to to rule so it'll be
interesting how the the Supreme Court
reacts to this uh but the more filings
we see from Smith the more we see this
this absolute priority that he gives to
shoehorning this trial just before super
Tuesday and it sort of flips the policy
of the Department of Justice which for
decades has avoided precisely that they
actually don't like trials before
elections they try to avoid
that yeah I would be surprised if the
court jumped on this uh Professor Turley
have a great Christmas great holiday hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else